hello I am xxxx swagman why hashtag ello
420 x6 and I will be giving you your
secret mission instructions today today
we will defeat the Illuminati
you must sneak into their secret
underground lizard place in front of
them up on 360 no scope 420 blaze it for
the good of all man
here is your standard-issue mal mal
blaster don't forget to drink Mountain
Dew and eat burritos along the way and
buy a new garage to bring cozy well
enjoy it
future of MLG is counting on you okay
fixed it it was because my playstation
controller was still connected hello
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
back a Matt the year 420 blaze it versus
X X X Illuminati xxx Wow
over 10 hashtag rekt edition montage
parody the game oh I'm not gonna make it
through this one it's like it's 2:00 in
the morning and I'm playing this game
right after I played an unbelievably
long session of fatal frame
oh good because I scarfed down a bag of
Doritos
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] I couldn't even hear myself over
what was going on in there Plato's it
was so I'm at a loss for what the hell
to say I think any words that I could
say would match the beauty of what's
going on in front of me this is gaming
at its peak I don't any was saying about
this biggest stupid game the game is
greatest I've ever played this is the
most fantastic spitting that I've ever
been graced with in my entire life
this is incredible do I get these gold
bars I can't even I can't I can't even
how am I supposed to even wait hey Wow
what am I supposed to Oh
oh god I think I'm supposed to be
lighting up a spliff but I can't don't
smoke weed everyday' only to remember
didn't always never smoke weed everyday'
that's very important don't do that to
the end
I seriously doubt oil design work I've
already said as much as needed to be
said which was that
[Music]
I'm pretty sure if I just let my
headphones bleed through to my
microphone though could but you would
have gotten the entire game louder than
it needed to be just do that it slowly
crap this is Gabe I need a breather I
need a breather because I can't handle
this [ __ ] oh god where am I now did I go
in this Shrek swamp
come on about just 420 blaze it with
Shrek okay can I get a different god
damn gun okay I don't think I'm supposed
to be one in the middle
[Music]
I think shrinks boning me right now oh
yeah I should stay out of his swamp to
reload dammit is that goddamn music
again the same question - but if I am
too
[Music]
but okay whatever I'm tired I'm just
gonna assume that that went over my head
[Music]
oh I life-changing orgasmic experience
at the hands of 420 Illuminati and this
is gonna rip it out from under me right
okay I guess we're all done here
so you can go home now and I can go home
now
which I can't cuz I got any of these
videos and then upload them and then go
to bed so I got another night whatever
check out the other videos that I've
done like this in the description below
there's one so thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]